welcome back everybody oh what a sight
that is where where's that a Rasha said
Malibu probably that Manhattan Beach but
that's beautiful as well that's pretty
nice a rush Mart kasi from the LA time
so kind to sit in with us and join us
now he is uh what do you prefer mr. USC
mr. la mr. South Bay I mean as far away
from USC right now as I can Los Angeles
I like Los Angeles all of Southern
California but particularly Los Angeles
and I love our hometown of Manhattan
Beach as you know so I I'm gonna ask you
this since you brought up USC and you
sounded like you wanted to stay far away
from Lane Kiffin on the Dan Patrick show
last week and they were talking about
how you guys had a torture on coach in
the building yeah and apparently
according to Lane there are some people
that didn't really like his voice and
didn't didn't really think that he'd be
a good fit there that was the thing that
attracted me to coach show his voice
voice I mean just such an amazing human
being an amazing recruiter I mean when I
look at what's happening to you I see
the number one thing that I look at is
where they are in recruiting they're not
even in the top 60 in recruiting none of
the top 30 players in the state of
California have committed to USC that
would never happen under coach OH so I
don't know where they would have been if
he would have stayed whether they be in
the playoff or not I can promise you
that they would not be like outside of
the top 50 in recruiting that is a joke
that's ridiculous where you are not
surprised by the backlash when yeah I
mean I was shocked when you came back I
mean you get a new president new ad you
bring a new coach so you get over 20,000
empty seats at the Coliseum you know the
only thing that's gonna reverse that is
if they have a really good season
obviously and people are gonna come back
but you have so many people who have
talked to you like long time for Trojans
season ticket holders who are just gonna
refuse to come they were just so upset
it's not that they had a bad season Dan
it was just that the culmination of the
last two years like they're they're just
not in contention right so you know I
mean I am really shocked that he's
coming back again he's a good guy
I think he's a good coach he's not a
championship coach no I get it I get it
and the thing about the pac-12 is they
are so much
relevant when USC is and from a national
perspective it's not just the SEC you
know it's not the one or two big 12
teams and the big ten that the pac-12
when us cease playing well when organs
playing well when you have two teams
that can be in the mix they're Utah
obviously had a good year this year one
of the reasons that I wanted to have you
in today was to talk about this
phenomenon that is brawny James who was
all over SportsCenter and all the
highlight shows this weekend LeBron
James son is a freshman at a high school
here in the LA area called Sierra Canyon
and st. Vincent st. Mary's which was
LeBrons High School in Ohio played
Sierra Canyon in a game and brawny who
is a freshman comes off the bench for
the team ended up basically winning the
game had the game-winning shot for
Sierra Canyon he plays with Dwyane Wade
son on this team and you were there at
media day and oh by the way it sounds
crazy that the high school had media day
media days and I think even the biggest
high schools even the big powerhouse
football schools around here like the
modern days and such now do they have
media days no this is something unique
although this is not their first rodeo
they last year they won the state
championship with Scottie Pippen son and
Kenyon Martin's son so now they got
Dwyane Wade son and LeBron James's son
and they had an immediate day and by the
way daddy when you talk about their two
sons they have a combined over 3 million
social media followers so a lot of young
kids want to watch them and I've said
they're the third most popular team in
this town right now you got the Lakers
you got the Clippers and you got Sierra
Canyon High School right now it's
incredible well to your point this is
when I realized it was real I have a
friend who has a junior in high school
in Manhattan Beach she's a good athlete
she's a water polo player and she has
literally been begging her father to get
tickets to a Sierra King his name so she
can go it's by the way people think that
they could just show up like it's a
normal high school game that's not the
case you have to buy a ticket and a lot
of their games are sold up it's so yeah
and some of them they're playing in an
act
well you know NBA caliber arenas and
here's the other thing I learned
recently rosh they have teachers at the
school who have to enter a lottery to
get tickets to go to the game so you can
work at sports information director if i
need to talk to someone on the team they
actually have like a PR guy that I
talked to they went to China for two
weeks prior to the season like a lot of
NBA teams do they're not just staying in
the state of California as you're seeing
I think they're traveling to twelve
states this year this is a traveling
show and yes it is still a high school
though you see and I know you haven't
been to a game yet but you went to the
media they do you see a lot of LeBron in
his son in terms of the mannerisms in
the way that he carries himself well
he's not allowed to speak with the media
yet so he has not I haven't talked to
him I mean he looks like his father
right and he has so when he's on the
court he has the same you know like Kobe
said that about his skin it's like I
like genetics or a real thing like I
could see myself in her and LeBron can
see himself in his son and so yeah
listen I I would love to sit down and
chat with the two of them at some point
this is ie R I've talked to him that's
Dwayne Wade son right and so it's a fun
team to watch and they're a fun group
together you saw the charisma of this
group and it's not just those two kids
they have a lot of really good young
players on that team why does this
school like Sierra Canyon the first time
I heard about this school I was in the
the locker room and NFL Network and I
was talking to Terrell Davis and I
believe they go from K all the way
through town and one if not two of his
kids were going to see our canyon and he
was going to a game that night this is
two or three years ago this was I think
this was the previous team that won the
state championship that you were talking
about he said man they have all these
great kids at these big time didn't want
prospects I'm gonna go you know watch
him play and see her Kenyon so I started
following him a little bit and then you
heard before LeBron came to LA that
Sierra Canyon was a possibility for
Broni and Dwyane Wade son but why does
it behoove a school to have a media day
and to have a basketball team like does
it actually generate revenue for the
school well so the coach said he wants
to put his players in a position where
there when they go to college this is
not a new concept for them so they had a
Midnight Madness as well they have all
that like what you would have it in
big-time college program they
have in highschool and so I think if
you're LeBron or you're Dwyane Wade you
want to go you want to put your kids in
a program first it's a really good
school that's first of all but it's also
they're not this is not new to them they
know how to play in a state championship
they know how to travel they know how to
deal with media so you know again there
was a lot of choices in Los Angeles but
Sierra canyons been in this position
before look at those crowds I mean like
this it is it's incredible it's packed
there's a lot of games that people want
to go to and like don't just show up you
need to get your tickets cuz they are
sold out more people to Sierra Canyon
game or a Rams game oh come on maybe the
Rams don't have that issue that place
was packed but it was all purple
yesterday yeah I'm very curious to see
how this is gonna play out with these
two teams in the new stadium it's a
gorgeous new facility I'm sure you've
toured the place yeah I have a hardhat
now I usually went once a month and they
gave me a hardhat they actually gave me
her hats I don't have to borrow one once
but the timing Dan couldn't been worse I
mean if they had had what the season
they had one last year this year that
would have been so much better for them
because then they could have seamlessly
transitioned into the new five billion
dollars so fie stadium but having both
teams have the season that they have had
they both got blown out and they're done
they're not gonna make the playoffs
obviously it's a tough situation for
them it is really tough because when you
look at the ticket prices that the Rams
want to charge for again the product
that they're putting on the field right
now it's not a bad team but it's not the
sort of championship team that we
thought and the Chargers are in a really
tough spot I mean they really needed to
have some success well especially with
the the lack of sales as you alluded to
rosh mark Ozzy from the LA Times here
with Dan Helle filling in for Rich Eisen
on the Rich Eisen show that we've been
talking about Philip Rivers in his
future here he's obviously in a contract
year is there any sense you get from the
times a year around the team what the
future holds in store for Philip Rivers
I think when he continues to have games
like he did on Sunday I think the the
chances are slimmer and slimmer that
he's gonna come back I just don't see
that happening I think they want to
transition I don't know who that would
be I've always said they need to make a
big splash this summer they need to make
a big splash whether that's a Cam Newton
and Chris Brock one's gonna hate
here this it should be their number one
priority to find a way to get Tom Brady
to Los Angeles that is the one guy that
would move the needle in the city I mean
if you put in a Tom Brady that's like
LeBron James right and I know it's for
two years but this is a critical two
years for that franchise you're trying
to sell seat license sinces you just try
to sell season tickets you cannot have
25,000 people in a 70,000 seat stadium
and that would not happen if they get
Tom so again we'll see what happens but
they need to make a big splash this
summer is it more important for them to
get a big name and make a big splash
than it is for them to set them tell
themselves up for long term so here's
the thing they go twelve and four last
year and I guess the problem was that
the Rams went 13 and three and no one
cared they didn't move the needle so
they do need to make a big splash it's
like Wayne Gretzky with the Kings you
need to get people to the games first
and if you bring in Tom Brady or if you
bring in a Cam Newton and the reason I
bring up these dances it needs to be a
big name a transcendent name we're like
if you're not a football fan you know
who they are that's important so listen
you need a win long term yes but you
gotta sell tickets you gotta sell these
tickets first cuz you can have a
half-empty Stadium and no one's going to
your games
what about to a tongue of a law that's
another big name is that big enough not
big enough yet cuz he's in college right
and so no one knows him yet and so I'm
saying again this sounds so simplistic
but like you just have to get people to
the games and so it's it's hard to
create hardcore fans first of all people
are talking about this 25 2008 iam that
is the worst situation for them why
because the cheapest ticket for that
Packers game was four hundred two
dollars the cheapest ticket for the
Steelers game was like two two hundred
dollars
those are hardcore Steeler fans those
are hardcore Packers fans those are not
hardcore Los Angeles Chargers fans
because I don't know if they if there is
a hardcore Los Angeles Chargers fan it's
hard like they just moved here and it is
a market that didn't really want them
because listen if we really wanted to go
to a Chargers game it's a two-hour drive
so that this was not a team that they
wanted here now they can still succeed
here but you have to find a way to move
the needle first no one's talking about
them right now so this is a football
team that's not going to the playoffs
they have the ninth pick in the draft
essentially that puts them in a position
to draft a quarterback like to who could
be a trend at quarterback a Cam Newton
would be an interesting thing to me
although what's going on there and we
just hear that will Grier are gonna be
the starting quarterback for the
Panthers in place of Kyle Allen will
Grier I believe a third-round draft pick
out of West Virginia gonna get his first
start of his NFL career but what this
tells me is that the Panthers clearly
don't have the next guy so they would if
they were gonna unload cam who was still
under contract and actually it's a
pretty reasonable contract for a star
caliber quarterback in the NFL around 19
million dollars a year they would have
to trade and then that in essence thinks
makes me think it is so would kim newton
be worth the 9th overall pick in the
draft no and not a top 10 and not a top
10 pick but maybe that second pick which
is almost like a first-round pick when
you look at how high that pick would
would be but the charges have to accept
the mentality that that you Rams did
when they came here remember like they
traded all those pick to get the number
one pick in the draft they really do
need to make a big splash that they get
the number one pick and that draft is at
Las Vegas and it's 2r and that doesn't
preclude them from maybe making a trade
for Cameron to be like the guy right now
and then 200 runs and whatever but you
got to make it a splash where the
Chargers are being talked about they're
just not being talked about and again as
simplistic as it is to just win we saw
they won last year they were 12 and four
last year they beat the Ravens at the
playoff last year and no one was talking
about them well the Rams having a better
season in the Chargers at eight and six
but on the outside looking in in terms
of the playoff race right now they're in
the seventh spot the 49ers and Vikings
have the two wild card spots the Rams
playing the 49ers on Saturday night it's
the nightcap of a triple header on NFL
Network when you look at this team when
I have to try to pinpoint what what
exactly has gone wrong to me is they
just everything operated off of the run
game and play action in the past so when
you don't have that run game going when
you don't have the ability to feed Todd
Gurley the ball and I understand why
Shaun McVeigh wasn't doing it early in
the season but I think he might have
just waited too long to try to get that
thoroughbred going yeah and
the offensive line that was the that was
the strength esteem last year and so
it's two parts it allowed them to run
but it gave Jared Goff the protection
none either has happened this year the
offensive line is in shambles Jared Goff
does not have the time that he had last
year Todd Gurley doesn't have the same
holes he's also not the same player but
the issue for them they're looking long
term look at those contracts that they
gave to Jared Goff and to Todd Gurley so
this is not just a problem this year
there's a problem moving forward but I
still can't believe the team that I
watched last Sunday night do what they
did against Seattle which is a very good
team what they put on the field against
the Cowboys the Cowboys team that had
not been a team with beat a team with a
winning record the entire season before
I could see the Cowboys going on around
here if that team continues but the Rams
has just been the v/line you need the
offensive line to be your strength of
that team Josh mark Ozzie with LA times
I'm not ready to pin it all on Jared
Goff certainly not Shaun McVeigh not
even Todd Gurley what I am most curious
to see long-term is does Todd Gurley get
back to be 80% of himself do they that
there's some kind of arthritic component
in that knee it's been reported in the
past Rams haven't really confirmed that
or talked about it Todd Gurley stranor
talked about it several months ago
that's that's what they're gonna have to
pin their hopes on if they need to
figure that out because if Tiger Lee is
not gonna be the tiger Lee that he was
before that Shaun McVeigh system cannot
work so whether it's moving on from Todd
Gurley or what they need to find it back
who can provide again maybe not what
Todd Gurley did a little high season but
something close to that yeah I don't
know if that's gonna be Malcolm Brown or
any other folks that are back there
right now he is a rosh mark Ozzie from
the LA Times what are the best in the
business my neighbor and good old beach
buddy good to see you thanks so much and
we really appreciate it for more of the
Rich Eisen show tune - audience Channel
239 on DirecTV for free on VR live or
download the Rich Eisen show app